[Applause]
welcome back
to another edition of down the middle uh
you want to talk credit you want to talk
fixed income you want to talk bonds do
those words mean
absolutely nothing to you they will they
will very shortly
uh i can't be any more pleased today we
have with us peter scheer
he's the head of macro strategy at
academy securities he's
only been around for a quarter of a
century in the fixed income
markets he he's seen everything from
the evolution of structured credit to
plain old
investment grade bonds in your
grandmother's bond portfolio
all the way down to the junk spectrum
and back and he's got geopolitical
insights
so we're in for a huge treat thank you
for being here today thanks a lot for
having me
i'm excited um so
walk us through for just novice
people who aren't so familiar with the
bond market
i mean you hear the numbers like 300
trillion dollars and it's kind of
meaningless but how big are the
the kind of the global how big is the
global debt market
how big is it compared to the global
equity market and how has it evolved in
the last 25 years
so it's much bigger than the global
equity market you know and i think
a couple things so i think in pure size
it's probably
300 trillion and it's mixed between
really i always think of it as like
sovereign and very safe sovereign debt
so
u.s government debt you know german
government debt italian debt
then you kind of move down the spectrum
into emerging markets
um and then you've got corporate debt
and corporate debt can really kind of be
defined as
there's investment grade then there's
high yield and then there's private
transactions so smaller deals
and you're kind of looking at that
entire spectrum and the other part that
i think people don't think about enough
though it's getting a little bit more
attention
there's this constant kind of rolling of
debt so debt's constantly maturing new
debts being issued
so you know every month the u.s treasury
is going to issue 30 billion
or so of 10 years 30 billion or so of 30
years and they're going to do that the
next month and they're going to do it
the month after
and those sizes have been increasing but
this is constant
evolution it's you know in the stock
market you get an ipo once
in every stock's lifetime occasion
there's add-on or secondary sales
but every single day there's new bonds
coming to market to replace the old
bonds so it's kind of an
evolving process and it's something you
got to watch and
you know i always try and simplify it as
you think about two things one is yield
risk
and so if you're in the u.s you really
think of what is the treasury yield
going to be
and it ranges from the short term to the
long term and the long term is going to
have bigger
impact and then you think about spread
risk and spread is that
element that pays above treasury so what
should investment grade company pay more
than
the u.s treasury premium premium yes and
i think if you kind of think of that way
you can kind of come up with
where the relative value is what's
interesting and often signals for what
it means for other markets like equities
because credit often does drive the
equity market
you know i don't think people quite
understand that uh you know
i uh when when jay powell came on i was
very much enthusiastically looking
forward to his leadership i had
when i when i worked for richard fisher
i knew that powell had followed my work
i knew he wanted to shrink the balance
sheet i knew he wanted to get rates up
to three percent
the shortest term rates and what people
don't quite understand
is how what happened halloween 2018
changed everything for jay powell who
has a background in private equity who
speaks with hedge funds who understands
the credit markets who understands what
things like duration are and yet when
the
the debt of general electric bonds were
downgraded on on halloween of 2018
it set off a daisy chain of events that
culminated in the issuance you're
talking about high yield issuance
closing down for 41 days that was a
record
and it bled through to the equity
markets
and how that terrible christmas eve uh
in the stock market was in 2018 and this
prompted the powell pivot
and but people don't understand that it
wasn't what happened in the stock market
it was what started with ge's bonds yeah
and so you had g
get downgraded and this was already a
time there was a lot of concern about
the size of triple b companies so you
had
budweiser bonds were struggling you had
a t was
struggling sure so some of these largest
issuers
and i think they started responding and
helping their bondholders and this is
something i talk a lot about
is we called it a debt diet so these
companies went on a debt diet and
started cutting back on i don't want to
interrupt but a triple b
bond is the right above the junk line
yes so people understand it and it's
what 50 to
53 of the market it's a big part of the
market and it is critical to understand
so there's a division between
what's called triple b minus is the
lowest part of investment grade and
double b
plus okay and it's actually a fairly you
know
small difference in credit but it has a
huge impact because a lot of
companies when they invest in bonds even
if they give it to an outside bond
manager
they will stipulate that it has to go
into investment-grade bonds right
a lot of pension funds and state and
local pension funds are exclusively
investment-grade bonds
so if you lose that triple b minus and
go to double b plus
it often cuts off a huge number of your
buyers a lot of insurance companies in
fact
become for sellers and it cuts off
access to the bank market in a different
way so
it's a very dramatic change it's just
because of all these rules that are in
place
you know i thought maybe in 2008 when
some of these rules became so
problematic
we'd see a smarter way to look at it but
we still have this
very you know finite cutoff between what
it means to be an investment grade
company what it means to be a
non-investment grade
and so these companies i thought felt
worked very hard for it but
this is coming up a little bit more now
in terms of esg
when they fought and did these things to
protect the debt they weren't doing it
because they liked the debt holders they
like they did it because
equity was prices were going down and by
solving the debt issue their equity
prices went
right up so the companies are always
trying to figure out what to do with
their equity in this case they had to
support the bond market
because it really was a bond vigilante
type thing and you know that term used
to get applied more to the treasury side
but um when credit investors got nervous
and the rating agencies got nervous
these companies had to adjust it because
it impacted their stock price
it's a great time right ge stock i think
got as low as six and you know
done very well since this at t all these
companies have rebounded very well but
it was an important step to address
their credit concerns
it's interesting you bring up att not to
focus on one company but
once ge was no longer the focal point it
seems like the market moves on to the
next
the biggest triple b issuer and so
now we follow those headlines very
closely simply because
of how it relates back to kind of being
the biggest player in the space in the
implications for the broader markets
um and you're right and that's what
caused powell to have to switch
from hiking and we've never hiked again
we have never hiked again and i had to
close down the j-pal fan club
so that i had found it on twitter in
public um
so take us back so here we are
in new york um you know i left wall
street in
2002 2003 i left wall street when i left
credit suisse
they were just starting to sell
collateralized backed you name it
obligations of some kind and i was
stupid enough to
raise my hand in a meeting and ask one
of one of the investment bankers at the
front of the room and is there a men's
time like who would buy the equity
tranche
who on earth would buy the equity crunch
now that was at the beginning
so walk us through kind of
the evolution of of fixed income
products that are
backed by other pools of of bonds
effects
of securities yeah and to me it's i
always look it fairly simply let's say
the u.s
treasury is trading at two percent and
some other assets
let's call it loans because they do a
lot of closer
three percent so it's a one percent
premium
you could buy that and that's a certain
investment base
and let's say it's a double b so it's a
limited investor base now let's say you
can tranch that up
and all of a sudden you can create a
large swath of a stuff that prices at
two and a half percent
so that same pool for a pool and let's
just make it a very simple 80 20 pool so
now gets prices this triple a and trades
at two and a half percent
that means you can get seven or eight
percent to that bottom 20
right and there are people who say well
that's like an equity type return that's
a really interesting return
and we'll do the work and it changes how
you think about it right the people at
the top level the cap structure
they don't have to worry if there's a
few defaults here or there because
they're protected against a fairly large
loss
so they think of it one way and the
people at the bottom end
kind of do the analysis they know
they're going to get some defaults but
maybe
even with defaults they're getting six
percent so they like it so it starts
redividing up that pool and i think one
of the important things was
leading up to the financial crisis so
much was getting triple a
and the thought process for aaa
investors sends to be much simpler
because you're like
triple a how much work are you really
going to do yeah it's bulletproof yes
and the problem then became it really
got applied to mortgages and a lot of
mistakes were made when they applied it
to mortgages
and everyone said well mortgages have
never gone down on a national
housing price has never gone down on a
national average greenspan famously made
that statement and his
his phd thesis which was finally
uncovered
when sebastian maloney was doing his
biography was was on housing bubbles
anyways
yeah and so that kind of they made
mistakes with that they made mistakes in
how they
did this tranching they didn't you know
anticipate certain things
and then they took those and re-tranched
them so they took these
aaa in this case triple b pieces made
another whole pool
created more aaa out of that and the
mistakes they made in creating those
triple b
on the rating side were remade in this
and that's what fell apart that's what
created the big short right and
you know it was kind of fascinating to
watch the big short and you know i know
people been talking
about that and the movie was great the
only thing i don't like about it is
actually the part i really hate about it
is a lot of people pick the housing
bubble
but they picked it in 2006 or they
picked it in 2000 and so the timing was
great
then the movie makes it sound like these
are the only people who ever saw that
this
every like there were a lot of people
who had these bets on but lost too much
money over time
yeah so their timing was impeccable they
did a great job with it
um but that's what happened is it
created such cheap ways to short this
and when it got went wrong it blew up
you know i mean and that was you know
i'll never forget
running into president fisher's office
and saying john thane just took 22 cents
on the dollar for
these subprime mortgages that the bank
was stuck with that when it was still
merrill lynch i mean it was
really dramatic to see uh
the effect of liquidity or the lack
thereof yeah
because most people you know who think
about the federal reserve
and the risk they took on they don't
realize that they were made whole
the the bailout of the subprime market
to the extent that the fed
did did bail out the separate market
didn't lose taxpayers
a penny right and that's the i think
people do underestimate just how
illiquid these things become
and part of it it's gonna sound a bit
silly but people will sit on a billion
dollar portfolio
and they're looking at it and they're
trying instead of making 1.1 percent
they're trying to make 1.12
so they're thinking in terms of making
that little bit extra
right and then when things start to go
bad all of a sudden like
oh my gosh i could lose a billion
dollars the reality is you're not going
to lose a billion dollars right
but that there's value there and that
mindset shifts and then you go to
sell it but it's invariably if you're
thinking that now everyone's thinking
that so where's the new money to buy
this
and because you get this leverage in the
system it becomes force-selling well
someone's now
lost all their money so they get closed
out right and that's really what
happened with
one of the bear stearns funds that kind
of was at the heart of that crisis
which always reminds me the one thing i
remember all of us i think saw it you
know
jp morgan bought bear stearns and i
think the original price was two dollars
per share
people are like tapping their screens
i'll never forget that i know they had
to up the price i think eventually but
it was like don't you mean 20 or so it
was like that was a shocking shocking
moment yeah it was i mean and that was
uh
i had i was pregnant with my twins at
the time
and and and i never had a free weekend
when i was at the fed
because every single weekend was like
where's asia going to open because
what's going to happen next because you
didn't know i mean
i didn't i didn't know what a german
landis bank was from a man on the moon
but we find out that you know that
they owned a lot of subprime debt i mean
it's just just the same way japanese
banks today own a lot of
collateralized loan obligations even
though they've started to step back
so before we get too deep in the weeds
can you explain the difference
just on a fundamental level between a
credit spread
and a yield a bond yield so when you
look at a bond a treasury yield
that's the yield and then if you look at
a corporate bond it will
yield something above that so again
let's say treasury the 10-year treasury
yields 1.6 percent
and a investment-grade bond yields 2.6
percent
that spread is the difference so 2.6
minus 1.6 percent and so
when you look at like an etf or a mutual
fund like lqd is a big investment grade
you can pull up the yield and the spread
on that and that yields really made up
from two things that's the overall
treasury yield and the spread
and that's when i look at risk right now
i do think treasury yields are going to
go higher
i think credit spreads can do fine but
investment grade bond prices
can actually go down as yields go up
because it's going to be driven more by
the
treasury component than that spread
component and it gets a little bit
tricky to think about i think that
there's a lot of confusion
i mean a lot of people just can't get
their head around
if the bond price goes up the yield goes
down i mean it's just
it i mean to to be an investor in bonds
to understand bonds you have to kind of
think backwards
in a sense and you know when i look
again if we talk about the etf space you
have something like an lqd which has
very long long-dated bonds so i think
the average maturity in there is
15 years right then there's something
that vcsh is a
vanguard short-term fund which is only
one to three years
so even if yields move a lot that
shorter data portfolio barely budges
right because that concept of maturity
which translates to kind of duration
means that it moves much more for every
well there's a lot more rollover risk if
your maturity is way out there
so so you've got all these kind of risks
that fact and so
which is why i think fixed income and
credit investing is really fun and
a lot of investors can do well in it
because if you have a
strong view of the economy what you
think it's going to do to yields
there's always a product you can do
floating rate loans if that's what you
think is interesting
you can move to shorter maturity papers
so it's really kind of a neat place and
i think people
they allocate you know maybe 40 or
whatever of their to
fixed income but they don't adjust it
often enough though maybe put it in some
big bond fund and just leave it there
and i think if they spent time on their
portfolio with the tools between mutual
funds and etfs
they could do really well in that fixed
income part so
etfs etfs etfs um two things
after the financial crisis dodd-frank
came along and
i don't think i mean i can't tell you
how many how many times i
i shared with president fisher the graph
of you know the bond inventories going
down the bond
the bond inventory is so far down it was
down 90 percent
um so what happened there and
separately what prompted janet yellen
right before her term was over
to openly express concern about
about bond-backed exchange traded funds
etfs
yeah so a couple of good things there
one is
dealers used to take on a lot of
inventory
and they would buy and sell bonds all
day long and that's how they made
money but they held bonds on their
balance right because
you know if say you wanted to buy a bond
for me
then i'd go and have to go and find
someone who owns that exact bond
and that's often hard to do so you wind
up building up a pool
you want to sell this bond you want to
buy this bond so i start buying all
these bonds
and then i have some to sell and
dodd-frank made that very uneconomic it
put much more capital on that
and it also caused a lot of issues of if
i bought the bond today and it went up
in price
maybe they wouldn't let me take that
profit despite the fact i did a good
trade
so you saw a bond inventory shrink and
at the same time you've actually seen
debt levels expand dramatically so
there's more
so i think that's we saw it during the
pandemic just
last year you get these wild price wings
because
you kind of have this much inventory
trying to go through this little
space and it used to be the inventory
wasn't as big
and the kind of holding container that
the banks had was larger right
right it was like a a cushion it was a
backstop
right so it kind of like acted as a
shock absorber almost right okay
now if the pressure seller if the
pressures
uh selling pressure kept going on
ultimately that shock absorber goes away
but it buffered much more it doesn't
happen as much now so you do get these
more wild price wings
and i think etfs contribute a little bit
to that partly because
if you're a normal person where would
you go to look and figure out what high
yield is doing
but now you can look at hyg or jnk and
you can day trade it you can do all
these things
and so i think people see that as a very
invisible
part of the market and they start
trading at discounts to net asset value
and that causes fear that causes selling
um one real problem that we saw
was at the during the pandemic these
short-term
credit funds which let's say they only
move one percent in a year like they
have almost no volatility right they
sold off three or four percent at first
but then they sold off as much as ten
percent but the net asset value was only
down three percent
so let's let's say the price should was
a hundred
mm-hmm it's now 92 but the theory should
be 97
and mutual funds that were similar price
to that were still priced at 97 because
they priced
so what people were doing was selling
the mutual fund to buy the etf
but that was causing the mutual funds to
sell bonds and i think that's the sort
of thing that the
fed and yellen as treasury secretary she
wants to watch how this interaction
works out
and what they can do with it and it was
no coincidence that when the fed
instituted all the
emergency responses back in march they
allowed themselves to buy
fixed income etfs and everything else
the fed did
in terms of the credit market was one to
five years or sorry five years and in
investment grade only but in the etf
space they could trade any etf
and so i think they understood how much
of a signaling effect that small market
i mean
i think it's less than one percent of
the market yeah but this was more
extraordinary than what
mario draghi had done i mean if you
think about the risk spectrum you know
right after equity you get to junk bonds
and the fed's buying a junk bond etf
did they peter did they have to do that
could they have
i mean at some on on some days
the quantitative easing they were buying
a hundred billion dollars a day
in in the very very beginning could qe
alone
have fixed no i don't think so i think
they want they had to address some of
these specific markets
that it's much harder for them to do qe
on anyways and the etfs are very
it's just so visible that i think they
get much more bang for the buck
and if they were trying to buy bonds
they'd have to figure out which bonds
were for sale they'd have to build out a
portfolio and they kind of get that
through the etf
um and the weird thing is i don't think
they actually bought an etf for several
months because they actually didn't know
how
they didn't have the piping to buy it
but the second they announced that they
could all these things rebounded
instantly so
it does show you the power of the fed
that they actually didn't have to buy a
single bond in that space or a single
etf
and they got the exact reaction that
they needed which was all these
discounts to nab
shrunk the selling pressure ended
because people couldn't attack that
market i think that was part of it right
you
couldn't attack it because you knew
there was a defense line either there
today or
coming down the pipeline and it was a
massive and that to me it's
you just look at how powerful that
psychology was knowing they could do it
and i think it was actually very good
though that they went ahead and followed
through because they fixed
that part of the market but they went
ahead and put the piping in place and
figured out how to buy etfs and they did
go ahead and buy some etfs so
i think if we get another type of
situation that emerges
and i expect it sometime in the next
five years again we'll get this sort of
period of volatility
i expect they'll put that plan in place
overnight and try and you know control
it much faster
well i mean we we don't have to go there
but pat toomey did
kind of draw a line and so the fed has
to come up with a
a new different kind of facility slash
emergency whatever it is
so in the process of basically
putting a floor underneath the fixed
income markets
a situation where corporate debt to gdp
was the highest we'd seen it now it's
even higher
is anything because any has anything
actually on a fundamental level on
balance sheets been fixed
no but i also i'm not that concerned
about credit
and i think for a couple reasons one is
you look at companies like an apple and
microsoft
that have issued a lot of debt yep and
traditionally a company with that much
cash wouldn't issue debt
but for a lot of reasons they went on
that path so
you almost have to subtract some of that
debt out of it or take away their cash
so
that part gives me some degree of
comfort um but i also
i look at it more how much equity is
there relative to debt
and so the equity and to me
you know if we start having any sort of
economic problems it's the equity that's
going to get
hit far worse because that's you know
and we've seen it time and again and we
saw it again with ge and the 18
they cut their dividend when they needed
they suspended stock buybacks so
i i don't think it's i don't see a
credit problem and if credit
starts becoming a problem it means
equity's been a big problem already so i
i'm
i keep a closer eye on the equity
markets as a signal
and i think we just have a lot of buffer
right now there's and and
you know even through this pandemic we
did have a number of companies default
so we've
cleaned some of the weaker entities um
i just think companies have especially
investment grade companies they have a
lot of
leverage they can pull to protect the
debt holders which ultimately they will
do
because they don't want to lose their
jobs they don't want to go into
bankruptcy and deal with that which can
often be messy so
um but to me it's when you look at i
look at
total debt versus total equity and the
total equity to
gdp is also probably at record high
that is one and the only other thing i
do sometimes
i i think too often we've also got to
make sure we're looking at global gdp
because mostly especially if you think
investment grade companies tend to be
s p 500 companies those companies i
think do 40
of their business overseas so we should
really also be looking at how much
you know gdp is there across the eu when
taking these into account and
it's still at record highs but it starts
looking at least a little bit better
because
those companies really are you know
global companies so i tend to look at it
versus global gdp which
again it's high but it's not you know
it's less so
okay and i'm hoping to be right on that
i think credit is going to be fine
um so let's stay on the fed for a little
while um
several things have changed in the last
12 months
um they're they're looking to average
inflation
making up for lost time i think we you
know prior to
the you know the shocking april
cpi print consumer price index print you
know
they had hit two percent i think
eight eight or nine times since they in
you know
put this target of two percent in um
what does
average inflation targeting really mean
and separately and you've written some
really interesting things about this
what what does what is adding
inclusiveness
and diversity to the labor mandate
to maximize employment what does that do
to fed policy
great question so i'll start i think
with the employment question
and you know i powell talked about it as
specifically about minority unemployment
at his last press conference and
they've been talking about it more and
more and to me this started late
november
i think they've looked at a couple
things what last time we got under four
percent unemployment
we didn't get inflation so that gives
them some degree of comfort but minority
unemployment was still i think believe
close to eight percent
and what they've seen in the past is
minority unemployment tends to really
respond
only extremely well as we get to very
low levels of unemployment
and since the fed is very blunt tools i
think they've made a commitment to try
and get minority unemployment down
and they would like to see that at four
percent or less and i think the only way
they see of getting that is to get
unemployment down to three percent so i
think they are going to let this economy
run
really hot and they want and they are
now specifically watching minority
unemployment separately
to make sure that that's responding to
their policy um they're making good
strides in that but i think that's a
very
different mentality than the fed had
before i don't think they
care about subgraphs right subsets as
much
so i think that's a big part of it and i
think
that kind of drags us into the inflation
and this is one where i got to be very
careful because
my job is to figure out what the fed's
going to do not necessarily what i would
like them to do
um so i think critical distinction so i
think
i think the fed has made a very strong
commitment to trying to drive
unemployment down to three percent
and part of that they think they realize
they're going to create inflation so
they are now looking at this long term
average and it's not new really i think
cochlear could tara i'm
sorry about that yes he's often talked
about looking at
average inflation so it's been out there
but it was never officially policy
and i just think they are going to
create inflation and the first wave of
defense is where we're at now where
they'll say everything's transitory
then we'll move and it's all of a sudden
been too long to say it's transitory
then they'll talk about two-year or then
five-year average inflation
and then we'll get to a point where okay
we have to do something
and we'll either see rate hikes and i
also think we'll see
i think people you know a lot of people
want to talk about the fed dots and the
fed at those meetings
sure puts out the dots of where they
think interest rates will be
i think they're very very committed to
not moving those front dots so i think
they are going to stay wedded to
not hiking but the market's going to
start realizing they're actually going
to be successful at creating inflation
so the terminal dots or the long-term
dots will actually have to go up
and that we have to get to two and a
half percent or something because we
will have generated significant
inflation
and i think they these are now just i
don't say they're excuses but that's
going to be their strategy
of why they don't have to hike but
aren't they playing with fire in a way
i mean this is a whatever the the
corporate bond markets how big 10
i think they're i think it you know
again
i'm not a big fan of going after this
inflationary
thing um and you know they run some
other risks right you're seeing housing
start to slow down
because people can't afford their
projects um what we have we had purchase
applications at the lowest level in
in a year yeah and you know you've
talked to builders they can't afford to
build if they
don't already have the material so they
and you're starting to see some of those
things like lumber and copper roll over
a little bit
but they're still at very very elevated
yes and that's going to hurt the economy
right because that's such a big part if
people aren't doing all these projects
and getting homes fixed
that's a big part of the economy so i
think we've got to be very careful what
we wish for in terms of inflation
um i think the other big element to me
has been
this whole push towards sustainability
um i think that's actually inflationary
i think we're going to see companies
realize
okay it might be more costly to produce
something onshore or move things away
from countries that we don't think are
doing a good job
and they're fine with that because i
think they believe and rightfully so if
they have a more sustainable
product or sustainable they can charge
higher right and their
p e ratio can go up as well because
there is an investment community that's
looking for that
so i think it's very different where
we're at and i think
people are going to start scrutinizing
supply chains even more not you know we
all kind of realize okay
supply chains maybe weren't super robust
we got to look at that but i think
there's going to be a lot more screening
like so why do you use this supplier why
are they in this country are they doing
something that we would not accept in
the u.s either to our workers
um i also think we completely failed in
terms of a lot of the health care issues
you know every mass that we wore was
still made in china
and 95 mass which are the ones doctors
get right
very hard to get in the u.s despite the
fact that they're made by u.s companies
in china there were restrictions on this
so i think we're going to see a big push
to
make sure that we do a lot more vaccine
vaccine production medicine production
onshore i think that's going to be
costly but i think it's a necessary
thing as
we just saw we have to have this in our
control
and we've seen chinese companies you
know kind of try and get around tariffs
if you will the wall street journal had
a good story about this
uh try to get around tariffs by going
into countries and just buying up
factories
and so and so that way they're producing
from
inside of another country but but you
you understand a lot about china first
of all
domestically how does china
and i think that they're they're pretty
serious about this because they're not
chinese officials are not reacting to
the pandemic
as they did even to the industrial
recession in 2015 2016 when they poured
a ton of money
in the industrial sector they really
seem to be focused on
shifting towards more domestic
consumption-led
growth but you've got some interesting
views on what that implies for global
inflation expectations perfect yeah and
so one thing about academy securities we
have 14 retired generals and admirals
who work with us as our gp that's just
fascinating it's really fun and one who
just joined us she's
actually was an astronaut i believe she
flew the first
shuttle after the challenger disaster so
she's great so
we get a lot of neat perspective and i i
think one thing that
we don't hear enough every day here that
we should always kind of remind
ourselves
everything reports to the communist
party in china at some level right
so every single company every single
person ultimately falls under the
chinese communist party the companies
have obligations to provide
information to china so i think even
private companies
yes there is really no such thing as a
such thing
right so they look and behave on the
outside but you know
huawei for example so one of our
generals general stewart who's been
great he was um
head of the department of defense's
cyber um
and i think he was involved in the biden
transition team so
he was he's always been very anti-huawei
and he's like if you get them
they will have the data and they are
obligated to pass that data back to the
chinese communist party if they request
it so
and they've got more than a third of
global telecommunications so they're in
a lot of places
yes and so i think you know i do believe
president trump was
actually on the right path when we're
trying to stop some of this and it's so
when we look at china i think that's i
you've got to think that everything
really is
at some level centrally planned
centrally organized
and they look and behave like us in some
ways
but not completely and so our generals
really pointed out too
at that alaska summit basically that was
the first time china said
you know you guys are doing it wrong
we're doing it right and
it's a very different attitude towards
china and i think that goes hand in hand
where i do believe
they've made that pivot a little bit to
where they're a more domestic focused
economy
we get some of that from the signaling
at the political level you've also seen
them let their currency strengthen
yes you have and i believe that's
because if they are shifting to a
domestic consumption-driven economy
the cost of raw materials is more
important than selling cheap goods
right so why wouldn't they have stronger
currency so they can secure those raw
resources
you've also seen china outsourcing right
china now sends a bunch of their low
quality production stuff over to vietnam
and other countries
so i think if they've made that shift a
lot of people are right now assuming all
these supply chain issues and prices
coming out of china are high and the
currency's high but that's just
temporary because
their first ones back from kovid i think
it's going to go much beyond that i
think they really are
saying we've hit a point where we're
much more you know focus our own economy
and even you look a little bit what
they're doing with tesla right they
invited tesla and they had it and now it
seems that
they're trying to smear tesla there and
produce their own electric vehicle
vehicles yep so
i think that's a big shift and the end
of all this cheap goods out of china
maybe something we have to get used to
which again will be very inflationary
globally yes and and they they've been
really focused on building up their
semiconductor industry
i'm glad you brought up semiconductors
because i think that's really important
and it's also very important what
they're doing with taiwan and
so if you go back to thinking about hong
kong
china the one thing they kind of
everyone said hong
kong was the center for financial and so
china would leave them alone
right and yet china built all those
facilities up in shanghai and other
places so that they could
replicate it and it made it easier i
think for them to
be aggressive with hong kong well china
has big
big banks yep so i think some of the
largest banks in the world are all now
chinese banks who are almost
non-existent 20 years ago
and in the semiconductor stuff i believe
they're doing that to undermine the
importance of taiwan right so
if you're in taiwan you start seeing
china compete more and more on
semiconductors so some of your
bargaining power goes away
and and just just to interrupt really
quickly i think let's put some
perspective on this
i want to say taiwan
exports 54 of global
semiconductors yeah i think it's a
number like that magnitude
right right right and so china wants to
subvert that importance
because china obviously wants to have
taiwan involved with it they're doing
military things they're encroaching on
their airspace they're doing that
but they're also doing these economic
things to undermine taiwan's importance
and i i think you start looking at this
game where they play in taiwan has to
sit there and say well china wants us
the longer we wait the less important we
are to them and we know china's still
going to be here in 10 years 20 years 30
years
we're not sure where the u.s interests
are going to be so i i think there's
going to be a test of this
administration to see
how willing we are to support taiwan
according to the treaties or not
um you know i think president trump was
very unpredictable which had an impact
and i think that people want to test if
you go back to the obama administration
i think we clearly had this policy where
we would talk tough
say there were lines in the sand and
then retreat from those lines in the
sand
so i think that's going to be tested and
we're seeing that globally with i think
ukraine where russia puts troops on the
border to see what we're doing
and i i think we're going to see some
more pressure mount in around taiwan
but part of it circles back to your
point on semiconductors
china is doing everything they can to
grow their economy
be competitive and i think they are
going to be much more inward looking
than just outward looking
and it's interesting that that you you
you look at the perspective
of taiwan saying okay 10 years 20 years
out you know
because they say southeast asia is kind
of going and if
another thing is if chinese if china
lets their
currency appreciate then they're going
to be a bigger economy in the united
states
quicker yes it's going to expedite that
right that's going to expedite that
and it's also very powerful i i think
we're almost in a global war
for these um rare earths and critical
minerals
and so explain what happened in
greenland recently
so i find this one funny because again
everyone trump is
saying said we should buy greenland and
everyone kind of laughed at the concept
and then just last month the wall street
journal did a really good article
on greenland where in various parts of
it china is trying to
what we call debt diplomacy so they will
lend to these projects
and they want airports they want ports
they want mining rights
right and ultimately that's how they
secure their interests
and i'm really concerned that the u.s
has some sort of vision of what we want
to look like in five years in terms of
greenness
and very little practical plan to get
there right i don't think china cares
where they are in terms of greenness
but they have a very practical plan in
terms of you know
getting the resources to do that so i
think they're ahead of us on that
and if 20 years ago wherever oil was
produced
that's where u.s interests were right i
think in five years wherever these rare
earths and critical minerals are mine
that's where our interests will be
and i think we're relatively behind
china who's already looks like that
and it's concerning and greenland was
just you know it was
so ironic that that's what they're doing
there and greenland according to that
article has 10
of the earth's supply of these rare
earths and critical minerals
10 percent um so
you know it's interesting you bring up
uh
kind of china being ahead of the curve
in the united states being behind the
curve
and debt diplomacy i i call it quiet
colonization
um because the sheer number of countries
uh that they've invested in as well as
commodities export exporters that have
become very reliant i'm talking about
latin america south america here
but even germany to a certain extent i
mean
i mean would you would you say that the
german economy is more dependent on that
of the united states or china
at this juncture i would say in china
again this is one thing that
makes me a little bit concerned is um
so the trump administration was
unilateral china we did everything we
did on our own we didn't care whether we
had partners
right of course and now there's a big
push to you know work with europe and
stuff to have a coordinated plan against
and the good part of that would be if we
could get coordinated with europe
we have bigger group and we should be
able to get more out of china my
concerns are
europe is not very good at making
decisions as we've seen with brexit and
so you've got a partner who's not good
at it but then to your point
their ability to separate from china is
much lower than ours
right you know um covet or
you know what was it the coronavirus
back then first hit in italy
and that's because italy relies heavily
on china for
their fashion industry so i i'm a little
concerned that
partnering with europe while it sounds
great is
going to be difficult because europe
doesn't make good decisions or doesn't
make decisions
and their interests are definitely
different than ours they are much more
tied to the chinese economy
again it's it's it's economics i mean
you know
here we sit today and an italian bank
defaulted on a
debt payment and i had to read the
bloomberg headline like five times i was
like what where did that come from
and but my point is that after the
financial crisis
they didn't use the excuse of a crisis
to clean up their banks
and that makes that makes them even
more reliable in a way because they're
they're more economically fragile yes
their banking system is
and everybody's relying on germany
and it's a strong balance sheet but then
germany is relying on
china yeah and i think it it's really
going to be this global
economic you know friction friction and
i think finally people have realized you
know that
i guess goes back to the early days when
we worked with china because we kind of
wanted a threat to
russia or something and there was always
this belief that somehow if we show
china the way they'd want to become
like us and china does not want to
become like us china is going to remain
china and they've got their own agenda
and that's to be
big and better than anyone else and i
think we're finally accepting that
and that's going to change how we look
at it and address this and
you know i i love your term of
colonization i've called it economic
colonization
china has gone and done a lot of this
say
and this comes from some of our generals
um we still have an opportunity to get
some of this back so
what we what i've heard from some of our
generals were involved in this
is five to 10 years ago we were also
pitching
places in north africa for access to
their and to work with us
and ultimately most went with china
because we tend to put all sorts of
strings attached like well you have to
have elections you have to do this you
and all things that we wanted and china
just said here's the money
and they went down the chinese pack
because it seemed easier but what they
realized is
china brought in all the workers to make
the roads and china acts as though the
resources are theirs which
i think if push comes to shove they
might be happy to make them theirs
so i think there's an opportunity for us
to go back in and re-engage with some of
these countries
and come up again maybe this is what we
need you to do but you can do it over 10
years
and not make radical changes and accept
some of the
issues that we didn't accept before and
maybe we can
kind of corral some of these countries
into our web right
because i think that's what's going to
be necessary to do or we're all going to
have
an ev power or you know ev automobile
culture without the ability to get the
resources
right and and you know i mean now is
kind of a critical juncture the imf
is bailing out most of these countries
and china
can't collect on its debts it's just
right and
you know i think that's when we go all
the way back to your questions earlier
about corporate credit
ultimately when the company defaults
the equity loses out and the debt
holders step in and they now own the
company
and that's kind of the cycle right it's
a default it's going to be the
debt holders come in and will own the
company i think that was china's
intention all along
these projects don't work and they come
in and take them over and they secure
access that's my port
yep that's my you know that that's my
rail line whatever it is i mean because
they've been so strategic in how and
people don't realize i i did the
research recently
they're investing in in europe
they're putting money into europe
european infrastructure
i mean these are very quiet things
they're doing but they're not small
dollars they're not small dollars
figures and you know i think when we had
the european debt crisis greece was a
great example where they went after
greek ports and stuff they go after
whoever is weak whoever needs money
yeah and they will try and go there
yeah i was in melbourne prior to the
pandemic
and i was on a waterway
and i said what a gorgeous port is
what's this is the biggest port in
australia and they said yeah china's got
a 50-year lease on it i said what
and i believe it's one of the reports
that our navy uses
as a like stopping area so again like
i i think people really have to think
about what's china's long-term goal
where are they
and i i i hope our policy
remains i want global trade i think
that's important and there's a lot of
things we can trade with china
i think we have to be very careful on
high tech and we've got to make sure we
protect our industries we protect our ip
um we protect our data and then at the
other end anything i think that's
medical and healthcare really we got to
make sure that
we have a lot more control or that it
goes to our closer allies or you know
mexico
something where we're not as dependent
on a country that clearly
we're frictionary with so um talk to me
about coincidence since we're talking
about china
um russia iran
china is all this happening at the same
time
by pure coincidence i don't know whether
it's officially coordinated but it does
seem
this goes back i think these superpowers
are
they all want to test us and they are
going to test this administration
and whether they're purposely doing it
together or just coincidentally but
i i think it's also very problematic
right because it's one thing to deal
with russia
it's one thing to deal with iran it's
one thing to deal with china it's one
thing to deal with any two at the same
time now you're starting to have these
three things come up yeah
um and each of these countries has very
different philosophies and attitudes and
i think we can when we talk say even
going back to china and taiwan
we can all talk about the treaties and
everything the us doesn't want to lose a
single
soldier right we china i
i don't think they would care if they
lost a million soldiers so right when
we're looking at all these you know gay
menship and where the threat is
i i think they realize that we have such
a different attitude towards life
which is great right but it is going to
make it very difficult for us to want to
enter something that's going to cost
lives
and i think the calculation for these
other countries is not the same
and certainly i'm not as much in ukraine
but when we look at the middle east
right
countries like iraq have to be cautious
with iran
and be nice to iran somewhat because
yeah it's unclear whether our interests
remain there especially now that we're
less dependent on oil so
and they've got nuclear there's a lot of
problems for mischief right now and
i do think things like cryptocurrency
enhance that
okay so that's that's kind of what that
that's where the train's going to pull
into the station
uh let let's talk crypto let's talk
um ransomware what what's happened
recently
uh in the crypto space and
are our regulators going to be because
of this big huge pipeline kerfuffle i
mean it was it was a mess i mean you had
yeah you had gasoline up here on the
east coast go up to like four dollars
just a matter and so it was very visible
to american consumers right
and it was really a transference of
digital into physical is kind of how
i like to think of it like you've seen
hacks and things before and you read
about it
but it's never really had this physical
impact and all of a sudden people
couldn't get gas in some states the
prices went
super high um and so we've been looking
at it a little bit from the geopolitical
lens to begin with so
first i think people are starting to
realize crypto makes sanctions kind of
hard to implement right right how do you
enforce
if if you can't see where the money is
going i mean
the irs said it was going to tax any you
know crypto
exchange north of ten thousand dollars
i'm like how are you going to see it
right
who's going to report that like it's all
so i think
things like that so you've got you know
iran okay
how are they selling oil probably in
crypto how does venezuela do that
um and one thing i find really
fascinating when i look at crypto i
think that supports that
is when countries like venezuela
something starts going wrong there
you tend to see crypto actually sell off
and you would think oh
it's heightened you know geopolitical
risk something like a crypto or gold
should rally
gold will rally but crypto owned i
believe that's because those countries
are selling some of their stores of
crypto
to fix the problem so i think there's
that realization and
and when crypto was maybe hundred
billion or something maybe people
weren't really you start to get bitcoin
alone as a trillion dollars right you
can move a lot of money to a lot of
nefarious things
and that brings us to i think ransomware
or that's you know
probably the biggest use case i think
still in crypto is people want to get
paid in bitcoin
um you saw that that or bitcoin or the
other you know crypt
um and you saw that again in this
pipeline case yep
the us government through fincent has
already
made it illegal for companies to pay or
suggest that companies don't pay
crypto through their us entities but
there's a whole cottage industry of
people who've set up now to help
companies pay for the ransomware
it's very prevalent that one company
that hacked the pipeline supposedly
already made 350 million this year i
know
i mean just it was again i i'm almost
relieved that this pipeline
crisis occurred as quickly as it as it
was
distilled but but it really opened
everybody's eyes to i mean
i mean they paid real money to these
people and
so i think there's and i don't know
whether you
saw but it looks in the aftermath of
this some of the companies that helped
supposedly make put the payment together
had denial of service attacks and stuff
like that so i don't know whether that's
us getting
back at the companies that facilitated
this so
i think ransomware is much easier to
collect
via crypto than it would be in dollars
sure and again we can track the dollars
we find out where it goes so
i i think the government's going to take
a really close look at
is crypto actually encouraging this
hacking behavior is it
creating greater risk ransomware and on
the other side of it i think we are
working you know
as some of our people are involved in
this we've got to shape probably a
better policy to really go after this
because
you know okay we know who did this maybe
nothing happens to them like oh slap on
the wrist right maybe china can tell us
what to do
because it seems like they're trying to
clamp down on their citizens ability
basically to hide money yes in crypto
yeah and
you know the use case right it's if you
think about it you the one thing
that makes sense is if you live in a
regime that's difficult and you're
scared of that regime
you want to use something like crypto
well china is certainly going to make
it difficult um you know i believe it
was two or three years ago i think china
every cell phone has to have facial
recognition
why is that um because they won't take
an excuse no someone stole my phone they
know it's you because it's facial
recognition right
and they want to track you they want to
punish you they will
and so i think they're going to do and i
found it really ironic some of the
crypto people get very excited when
china showed more and more interest in
crypto
and i was like i think this is a bad
thing for the existence china wants its
own digital currency
right you you can go on ant today if
you're in in
in shanghai and check out with the
digital currency yeah it's it's
it's part of the shopping bag and it's
one of your options to tie this all full
circle back to where we were with china
you know switching how they
they view their economy and where they
stand right i think they want their
currency to appreciate i think they want
to become
more considered as a reserve currency
and i think that's also why they're
early to the digital right
it will allow them to do things that
can't be done with physical dollars that
i think will encourage people to use
their currency more so
they've got this multi-pronged strategy
and i think digital currency is
going to be bad for crypto but it will
actually again push
china's currency more into you know
a reserve currency type status i don't
think they get to reserve currency
but that seems to be their plan they've
been pushing on it from every angle and
that's just
another one i i completely agree with
you um
one last question peter what does it say
about
the crypto space in general that one
individual can go on saturday night live
that one individual can say oh wait it's
got a nasty carbon footprint i mean how
he didn't know that before
who knows but what does it say about you
know
chief financial officers of the world
that they're actually
well if elon musk has said if tesla owns
bitcoin then we can put some of our
corporate cash in it and then if
he says no then they all i mean what
does it say about i think this phenomena
i think this put a huge dent into that
sort of progress if you want to call it
i think companies that were reluctant or
like
kind of being feeling they were forced
into it and yeah part of it is because
there's such little yield on anything
these companies have cash they're trying
to figure it out they can earn you know
and bitcoin was looking like an
interesting alternative especially with
elon musk saying it was there
i i think people have to take a really
hard look at that and say
this isn't a currency it's a asset of
some sort
right definitely not a currency it
doesn't really behave like a currency
and i think this recent price action
should be scary i think they do have to
think about the
you know how much energy usage is there
i've heard if you know
crypto was a country it would be the
10th largest energy user gosh
and and like 50 60 is mined in china
correct and
i'm sure it's no coincidence that china
also built more coal-fired plants last
year than the rest of the world like
so i i think people have to really think
what does this all mean and you get some
people who say
well it's really just going to push the
advent of green technology i don't think
so and i think there's a lot more going
on than just elon musk but
that volatility is insane and even on
the way up i've always questioned you
know
if you think of a normal asset right and
you want to buy a 100 million dollars of
something
you try and do it quietly you try and do
it so you get the
lowest price possible right it's very
unclear to me whether some crypto stuff
wants to
trade it inefficiently so they drive the
price from 40 to 50
000 on a relatively small number on a
sunday afternoon right and you don't
know how many transactions
like and you hear about all these
transactions but even if you think about
the stock market right
the transaction volume it's all because
one trade leads to ten other little
trades like and there's all this going
on
i suspect that the crypto community is
not as robust as we
think and the depth of liquidity isn't
really there
and that some of these actions that have
taken place may have been purposely to
push up the price
i always kind of think of you know three
rules of crypto but the one rule that
always comes to me there are no rules in
crypto
um and they're starting now trying to
force things like again everyone can
write about
whatever they want on crypto say
whatever good things they want there's
no verification there's
and you know wall street crack down on
that you had to actually you know
talk about your companies you couldn't
lie like there were a lot of things sure
and none of that was like the wild wild
west right there's no sec
enforcing it and that's part of you know
i guess it's charm but it's part of the
dangers like you really have to
understand there are people who have
heavy heavy incentives
to get you to go into crypto and i'm not
always against crypto i wrote
you at the start of this year i was
asked you know three interesting
alternatives and i wrote buying crypto
because it was only 30 000 at the time
and i felt there were more and more
places accepting it the use each case
was going on
and then i've grown to dislike it and
you know i like disliked it at 50
it went to 60 it got to 30 now 40. but i
still don't like it i think
something's changed to me and i think
we're going to get a lot more government
regulation
and this awareness that it's really is
still
too much of a criminal elements involved
right well i um
you know this is it's going to to be
determined because there's an entire
generation
that's got their eyes on this um well
let's uh
let's do this again in about a year and
we can talk about where dogecoin is
oh my gosh or whatever new one is
exactly thank you so much for taking so
much time peter
i really do appreciate it thank you so
much i hope that now
you know that when bond prices go up
yields go down and that you've learned
a lot about the credit markets uh that
was an incredibly wonderful
deep dive with peter shearer uh and i
would invite you
there's another expert that i recently
interviewed christopher cole
if you want a similarly deep dive into
the volatility markets
then have a look at that episode if you
missed it and i look forward to the next
time again if you haven't subscribed
please do so now
and i'll see you next time for the next
episode of down the middle thank you
you